[Applause]
earlier this month yale university made
the news when its art museum had to
surrender over a million dollars in
artifacts that law enforcement say were
stolen but what if yale isn't alone in
fact what if a shocking amount of what
you see in museums is stolen and often
from people of color i'll explain in a
segment called how did we get here
[Music]
let's talk about museums a great place
to go if you want to seem classy while
looking at naked people
our show is filmed in new york city
which is home to
some of the best museums in the world
like the met the museum of modern art
the guggenheim and of course the whitney
which i recently discovered is not a
shrine to whitney houston
i wanted to dance with somebody while
security guard was all like man we're
going to have to ask you to leave and
that is fair
but as much as i love museums it's
important to recognize that many of them
have some real issues
as i mentioned the yale university art
gallery recently had to surrender a
bunch of its artifacts to law
enforcement because they're being
investigated as stolen goods the art
allegedly came from a smuggling ring
that was responsible for the theft of
objects valued at more than 145 million
dollars
so even though the museums or
foundations paid for the artifacts it
turns out they don't actually own them
it's like if a guy stole my car and then
sold it to someone else the new owners
still have to give me back my car and
they should also have to detail it
because it's full of crumbs
so this is a really clear-cut case a guy
allegedly stole a bunch of stuff and
when people realized it the museums had
to give the stuff back but what if
instead of one person it was entire
countries doing the stealing and what if
museums have known for decades that they
were displaying stolen goods because
that's actually what's going on with
museums all over the world
to explain let me introduce you to the
royal museum for central africa in
belgium i know i just heard myself say
those words too
yep that's not where a museum about
africa belongs and the more you think
about it the worse it gets so people
from belgium went to africa looked
around and decided what's important then
they stole it put it in a museum and
showed it to their little friends
that's why when you watch black panther
some people think eric killmonger is the
villain and some people think he's the
guy making some good points
now
a little background here
yeah i know i cheered for him too in the
theater
but mostly for the haircut his hair is
untouchable
now a little background here back in the
1800s belgium was run by a guy named
king leopold ii on a side note that man
could absolutely go to a hipster party
in brooklyn tonight and not stand out in
any way
now this belgian hipster here decided he
wanted part of africa for himself so he
took it and because he obviously didn't
understand the concept of irony he named
it the congo free state which is a
little bit like calling chuck e cheese
the restaurant where no one ever pees in
the ball pit
it's just false advertising now leopold
looted and destroyed everything he came
into contact with in africa and because
of his brutality about half of the
congolese population died then after
stealing everything he could from the
african people he hired an architect to
build you guessed it the royal museum
for central africa then proceeded to
fill it with the stuff they stole from
the africans whose homes and families
they had destroyed and that's the museum
still sitting there today which is
insane that place has more of a haunted
legacy than the basement and get out
now
obviously the belgian museum is an
extreme example but museums all over the
world are proudly displaying stuff that
was stolen from other cultures which
isn't that surprising it turns out
people in egypt weren't like yeah girl
take my ancestors mummified body and let
second graders get peanut butter all
over it on a field trip
but however bad you're thinking all this
is it's actually worse because according
to unesco currently 90 to 95 of
sub-saharan cultural artifacts are
housed outside of africa that's like
finding out 95 of the real housewives in
atlanta live in duluth now
part of you might be saying but isn't it
good for people to see artifacts from
other cultures aren't these museums
doing a service and the answer is sure
sort of but even if you're doing
something good you don't get to do it
with stolen stuff remember when someone
stole my car earlier even if the new
owners are really nice people who are
using it to drive a bunch of nuns to
choir practice it is still not okay but
it is a fantastic idea for a sister act
sequel
now
i'm not saying you can't have objects
from other cultures in your museums or
that it's not important to be exposed to
art from other places but we do have to
find out where those objects came from
return some artifacts to their proper
owners and display others in their
appropriate context and the good news is
many museums today are really trying to
improve the royal museum for central
africa even closed down for a few years
to try to provide better context for
their displays the museum of men in san
diego announced that they would no
longer display human remains without
tribal consent which is good news but
also oh my god they were doing that that
is the most disturbing san diego related
news since we lost this woman
where is she
carmen for the love of god why can't you
just settle down
but
there's another way to make sure that
art
from people of color is ethically
sourced get it straight from artists
let's showcase more contemporary art
from artists of color and finally
museums need more people of color in
leadership positions according to a 2015
study only 16 percent of leadership
positions at art museums are held by
people of color
and it's not acceptable to have museum
leadership that is only slightly more
diverse than the cast of young children
museums have a rough past but they can
have a bright future many of them have
the power and wealth necessary to start
righting their wrongs and to establish a
more equitable arts industry so it's
time for them to step up and if they
want to start with the whitney houston
exhibit at the whitney
i wouldn't be mad because i believe that
children are our future this has been
how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you